[Music]
okay game two
cracker atm let's go e4 this time
and i'm going to disable the alerts
while i play the games
if that makes sense because when i put
this on youtube um
when i put this on youtube people like
it when there's like uh
uh you know a specific kind of people
like the flow i still
this does not diminish my appreciation
for the support and i'll re-enable them
like after each game so he's playing the
scandy he's playing the scandigo d4
and um basically the queen d6 line is
legitimate that is a
variation of the scandy that rose to
prominence recently
but the way that we play this isn't
really substantively different from
other scandies we just develop our
pieces and control the center there's
nothing
crazy that we have to do here but um
you know we have to be very careful
because he's immediately applying
pressure on the pawn
what is his next move going to be and
how should we deal with that move
what is his what is his general scheme
of development here
so he's clearly applying pressure on the
pawn which means what does he want to do
he wants to go bishop g4
and the sort of russian school of chess
move is what
well d i'll explain d5 after the game
but i'm a little bit worried
that pawn will be insurable let's go h3
not a move i love to play
but it really annoys the hell out of
people ah now i can't put the bishop
here and putting the bishop okay now he
goes a6
but i didn't even really want to put the
bishop on b5 where should we put the
bishop where can we put the bishop now
now that we've dealt successfully with
his main idea
we can develop actively and that
involves a move like bishop c4
and now if we're thinking about pushing
our pawn to d5 at some point
it's easier to do that now we're just
going to castle and where should this
bishop go
and we've been through this many times
this is like the natural classic square
we just bring our pieces into the game
yeah black can play e5
yeah bishop g5 is right bishop e3 would
be slightly more passive although a case
could be made for that as well
now um we're gonna make another well he
wants to play rook d8 we still have to
be very careful about
protecting this pawn at the same time
i'm not too worried about that what i am
slightly worried about is
the move b5 i don't want to let him go
b5 with tempo and then fianchetto his
bishop so how can we stop
can we stop that we're we're kind of
playing prophylactically this game
trying to annoy him let's go a4 exactly
this is a common move at like a gm level
you'll see this all the time in various
positions and if he goes rookie which i
think he will
yes he does um this is not a problem
what we really want to accomplish here
i've talked about this many times
the best way to defend the pawn is with
another pawn so it would be very nice if
we could play c3
and freaking forget about this problem
once and for all how can we go about
doing that
while not blundering the pawn in the
first place yes we could go 92
this knight could re-maneuver to g3 a
slightly more active square
and as necessary we could play the move
c3
okay so queen b4 is one of those moves
that looks intimidating
but i don't believe it really is because
the reality is queen takes b2 is going
to be
you know it's going to be unthinkable so
we can go bishop b3
but then he might go knight a5 and keep
harassing us
so let's see if we can defend this
bishop with something
can we kill both problems at once
yeah we can just go b3 we can go b3 we
don't have to even worry about queen
takes b2
and if he goes knight a5 the bishop can
drop to d3
and aim itself at the king so the queen
on b4 is kind of stuck in no man's land
we can take on e7 we can also drop the
bishop to d2
either move is good let's take let's
simplify a little bit
leaving him with a bad bishop and now
let's involve our rook and x-ray the
queen discouraging him from playing e5
and we can then bring our knight out to
g3 which we're gonna do
and kind of complete the x-ray slightly
better for white here he goes queen f6
where can this knight go from here where
can this knight go from what would be a
nice pathway for the knight
who can tell me yep knight e4
excellent and white is slightly better
here nothing extraordinary he plays he's
playing well
queen h6 and from here he could go to c5
but
we shouldn't necessarily rush with that
although that is very tempting so i'm
gonna do it
although he can go back to c8 here and
uh he's doing fine but we're gonna start
piling up on him what does it mean to
pile up
we need to look at the center we need to
ask ourselves well are there squares
that we can access in the center for our
pieces
what comes to mind what squares can we
jump onto
well he goes b6 so all right so that is
interesting we
could consider taking this funnel though
i don't love that
what we're gonna do instead let me think
about this
is let's drop the knight back to d3
so that we can go to e5 so notice i'm
doing all these maneuvers it might seem
mysterious
what i'm essentially trying to do is
optimize the placement of my pieces i'm
trying to find the best central squares
for my pieces
and the move b6 is something that
hopefully we're going to make him pay
for he's
creating these you know these weaknesses
on the queen side
and eventually one day hopefully we'll
be able to exploit them
now which knight do we want to put on e5
uh that depends on what he does
although i like putting the f knight so
that the queen has
access to the king side squares in case
we want to get started on an attack
uh the perk of putting the other knight
on e5 which is what we're gonna do here
is that the bishop can then drop back to
d3
which is what we're gonna do and aim
itself once again
at the king okay and now
look his position is getting more
passive oh and he's missed a very nice
retreat for the night where can we go
and what immediately do i think of when
i play f6
is this the pawn on e6 look how weak it
is so what we need to be doing is
bringing the knight back with tempo
his queen is almost trapped okay oh he
goes here
and now we can just take the pawn and
once that pawn falls
his whole position is going to start
collapsing we are actually threatening
something
really really cool i'm anticipating this
move
i'm anticipating bishop f okay he goes
f5 and he doesn't defend against it
look very carefully at the queen it has
no squares
can we attack it yes we can
g3 traps the queen the rook on e6
guardian d6
the knight's defending against the other
squares he's gonna have to give his
queen up for two pieces
that's actually really cool
so you can see the pressure rookie 4 he
had d6 so that's why we put the rook on
e6 not only to take the pawn
but also to deprive the queen of that
square
all right so we put the pressure on okay
so knight c3 we shouldn't panic gonna
move like this
we should ask ourselves oh so he finds a
defense
but the reality is he does it at a great
cost to his position now if we were to
move the queen
he'd take the knight so let's take his
queen and the funny thing
is we now need to find a way to win the
maximum amount of material so what
should we do here
what we should do is realize that both
knights are hanging
okay both knights are hanging what does
that mean with my turn that means if we
were to move this knight away
then he would not be able to save both
knights at once which is what we're
going to do we're going to go knight g
to e5 we're not going to take any of his
knights
because then he would take hours and
attack the other knight
and now we're going to win the knight
and if he goes knight d5 which he's
probably going to do
we're going to pin that knight with
bishop c4 now let's simply activate our
pieces knight to g5
we're going to go for checkmate here
even though it's an end game once again
look at the amount of pieces that are
next to his king this knight wants to go
to e6
and then we're going to take g7 the game
is basically over
yeah so things are getting more
complicated but we're following the same
logic that we've always followed none of
my moves should be like
that mysterious so a move like bishop c4
involves some tactical vision
he's put his knight on the same diagonal
as his king
so now we can do a bunch of different
things we can go rook d7
yeah we're going to do that because the
reality is if he takes on d7 then we
take
then we take on d5 and attack his rook
on a8
so there's some tactics none of them are
whole you know unbelievably difficult
here for example what should we do here
you know we should notice that the rook
on a will be hanging if we take d5
what should we take d5 with and we
should just take
just safety five and bishop takes or
rook takes would also be fine
here we can take either rook it really
doesn't matter i should play a little
bit fast because i'm
low on the clock and he resigns great
game
okay so he played the scandy
and queen d6 has gotten quite popular
lately even a book has been written
about it and now h3 to stop bishop g4
uh we're just developing our pieces
white is slightly better here a4
stopping b5 now knight e2
right a lot of people would look at this
move and say and it's a retreating move
i don't really want to retreat
we're at the level when you can't think
that superficially retreating moves can
be
perfectly fine and i've made that point
for a very long time
so we want to play c3 ultimately to
permanently secure the pawn on d4 so
this knight
could get relieved of its duty and come
to g3
okay so queen b4 now b3 if we had gone
bishop b3
he goes knight a5 he attacks the bishop
and if we move the bishop we have to
deal with queen takes b2 that's kind of
annoying
okay so b3 knight d5 we take on e7
leaving him with kind of a passive
bishop now we go rookie one
x-raying his queen knight g3
94 knight c5 like just improving our
pieces and now knight back to d3
so the reason we don't take his bishop
is there's no need to do that
our knight is good his bishop is bad
that's a simple cost-benefit analysis
and it helps him get his rooks to the
d-file thank you jtm waffle
um there's no other good square for the
knight so again it's technically a
retreating move but really it's not
because we want to reroute the knight to
e5 which is exactly what we do
so he goes knight c7 we go knight d5
the reason i didn't play knight fv5 i i
mentioned that we might play this move
but the bishop is kind of stranded here
and um
i didn't want to leave it strandy it's
like b5 idea is kind of nasty why didn't
we take a6
so that is i wouldn't say that's a free
pawn because
let's approach this and like what is my
intuition today what is my brain telling
me my brain is telling me look this
knight is stranded
that should make sense to everybody the
knight is no way back
and what he can do is he can just defend
the c7 pawn and guess what
i don't want to deal with this just for
a pawn like who knows if i'm going to
get my knight out maybe i am i don't
think he's going to win the night
but this leads to complications that are
not worth a pawn
pawns are just like not that valuable in
the grand scheme of things
in the middle game and i didn't want to
engage in this particularly in a blitz
game and by the way
as xcsme points out yeah bishop c it
needs to be dealt with but we can take
the knight
and open up this evacuation route
okay okay so
nice d5 bishop e8 now we go bishop d3
aiming the bishop at the king
and the move f6 is the decisive mistake
um
how did i immediately know what to look
for well again i often mention
formative games in my chess career where
i committed mistakes
similar to what my opponent does and
there was a game that i have previously
shared in the context of a funny story
um but that game itself has instructed
value i've made this very similar
mistake myself okay it's not like i'm
immune to this kind of stuff
and my 2700 rated plus opponent
failed to perceive this exact type of
weakness okay
so watch this i'm going to find this
game and i'm going to show you
it's my game against dimitri jakovenko
who is a russian super grand master
and i literally made i would say a very
very similar
slightly more complicated version of it
but a very similar mistake
yakovenko 2737.
i've shared this game before 2015.
so basically as as black here i was like
i'm annoyed as hell at this knight
i'm gonna chase the night away with f6
okay rebel thank you for the stuff
and i failed to appreciate i failed to
appreciate
that um that i'm weakening the e6 pawn
because
in my mind i was ah the bishop's
defending it but guess what the bishop
it turns out is overloaded
white has a very simple overloading
tactic that my opponent also missed
because it doesn't often occur at like
the gm level people don't usually
blunder this kind of stuff so what is
white's move
and people are going to see this very
quickly the bishop is overloaded it has
two
jobs both of them are very weighty so
knight takes c6
and let's say black plays rook takes c6
it doesn't matter
and eventually you go queen takes e6
you've won a second pawn
and you win the bishop and white is
completely winning why does two pawns up
black can win one of them but now after
rook a2
everything is protected a6 is going to
collapse black's pieces are scattered
and black is just lost here it's not
quite resignable but
white would have won this my opponent
after thinking for like five minutes
goes knight back to d3
well it's not that simple but i'm sorry
but like this is a game between the 2700
2600
everybody should follow at least the
principle here so i've done this before
the same exact type of mistake and
i really want to emphasize that even
though the close might be different
the sort of type of mistake is exactly
the same
so be very careful about weakening those
central pawns that's
yeah we laughed our asses off exactly
that's the ultimate
goal here knight g4 rook takes c6 and
now detecting the queen queen is trapped
and we simply go g3 attacking it and
trapping it
okay what if he did f6 before 97. so if
he did have six here
then there was no way to win the pawn
directly but it's okay i mean we could
have gotten the queen e2
or i don't know rookie four okay
childhood
blender's a fork on c3 so uh we could
have done something like this and
and centralized the queen uh yeah he
could have gone knight c3 and forced the
exchange of queens but
that exchange of queens is not
necessarily horrible for me
so i don't know there's details here but
um
the bottom line is the bottom line is
this is like the
the arc of the game how do we see that
the queenest chapter well
we've had games before we've had games
before
where we trap the queen sort of in the
center of the board in the middle game
and you should not exclude that
possibility even if the queen may seem
safe
but i i can see that the queen is
surrounded by a lot of traffic there's a
lot of pieces in the vicinity of the
queen
no gm neroditsky coaching at gmail.com
and that sort of alerts me to the
possibility that
the queen might be out of breath out of
air and so g3
uh traps the queen okay
so yeah it just looks trapped and rookie
four doesn't trap the queen as some
people asked because the queen has the
d6 square although that's very close
all right
any questions or maybe may we move on to
perhaps the final game of speedrun
today as i said this is a bit of a short
stream
well bishop f7 doesn't actually oh yeah
he goes knight c3
and here we just go 95 we transformed
the advantage into winning a knight
he found a way to get his queen saved
but um
he loses a piece in the end game and
that's just a disaster
oh yeah c5 sorry he could have gone c5
and opened this up
i missed that yeah yeah yeah c5 or c6 i
mean it's still miserable but
you're you guys are right good job yeah
c5 or c6 and the queen has evacuation
squares on b
and c7 but i can go c4 and
dislodge one night from the other thank
you wasted and wounded for the two
months
2205 miguel tall okay that's a pretty
intimidating name
all right let's go with another let's go
with the modern um
and i played the modern increasingly
just to show how these hyper modern
openings are played thank you symphony
and basically to reiterate what we're
trying to do here is we are giving white
control of the center
yes we are but then we're using our
pieces as snipers from a distance
to chip away at that center and attack
it with our pieces and then with our
pawns at some point
so that doesn't mean we don't need to
complete our development we need to
complete our development
and he goes bishop c4
now bishop c4 as we've discussed on
several occasions
there is a small tactical idea here
that um can allow us to liquidate and
sort of simplify the position and
actually equalize
could somebody remind me of what that
idea is
and and you should think about this
whenever there's a bishop on c4 knight
on c3
those are the contours of this tactic
knight takes c4 and then d5
winning back the piece okay so he goes
bishop f7 that's an intermediate move
people often play
but it's not actually that good because
it gives us the f-file
and it gives us the two bishops however
our king side is slightly weakened so
that's the rationale behind it now this
knight we need to be careful
because this knight can go to g5 and
cause us some problems we have a weak
square on e6
so before we do anything crazy we need
to take
care of the passageway of this knight to
g5 and e6
what move allows us to do that yeah now
you guys might look at this move and say
well
aren't you weakening your king's side
even further we kind of are
but it's more important to prioritize
stopping nitro5 than anything else right
now
and now we can continue our development
so we can play we can play a lot of
different things we can now play d5
actually control more of the center and
get this knight out of e4 permanently
if we do weaken the e5 square but we can
control that square effectively by
getting
getting
our knight out quickly and perhaps even
at some point playing the move e5
to fully liquidate that weakness okay
knight c5 is a really good move
because his knight can swing back to d3
we don't need to play b6 here
uh because that would actually help him
we can actually just continue our
development with knight c6
and uh then we can bring our queen out
to add some more beef
to the protection of the five square
well this is beef this is like filet
mignon that he just gave us
and that's the thing you know when
people are up against these
unorthodox positions they tend to make
more blunders which is why at this level
i do recommend people to look into
openings like the modern
okay so queen d6 here falls into our
plans and it protects g6
and now by the way we can go b6 and get
the night out because the knight no
longer has access to the d
to the d3 square now we have an extra
piece
but let's not relax let's try to let's
try to play precisely
what does it mean to play precisely we
haven't completed our development
okay just to remind people of the
importance of
completing your development even when
you're up a piece bishop f5 is a
perfectly fine move
we just got to be a little bit careful
about a rook which is sort of stranded
it does have the e4 square though but we
just got to pay a little bit of
attention to it it is defended
now i'm looking at this knight on b3 and
i'm saying we need to use our pawns
to open up the queen side how do we do
that
we have a very very thematic maneuver
here that knight on b3 is a sitting duck
it's a sitting duck because we can
advance our pawn to a4 if he plays a4
he weakens his queen side he does our
bidding for us
so and if he doesn't we can advance the
pawn to a4 at least perhaps all the way
to a3
get his knight back to a1 and induce
more weaknesses and we can even lift the
rook up through a5 to b5
so we do a million things with this one
move
well g4 would also blunder the knight or
g3 would give the knight up but even if
it didn't we have the e4 square
okay now we need to be careful we need
to you we need to put on our tactical
hard hats
we're on a construction zone we have
several ways to capture this knight with
the knight in the bishop i know most
people are thinking you can't take with
a knight
but let's give that a try if we take
with a knight and then he takes queen
takes f4
i'm seeing that the queens have a
standoff and at knight takes e5 queen f4
what move does black have there
knight d3 check winning the queen how do
you see that how do you even let your
brain
find that it's a mentality thing you've
got to at least consider what happens if
i do it anyway
can i spend another 10 15 seconds on
that key position
he can take on d5 but a queen train is
perfectly suitable to us we're up a
piece
and um if he doesn't trade queens then
we've won another pawn we have preserved
our dark squared bishop yeah okay he
takes
okay now we cannot take it after our
bishops hey let's move the bishop
we can move it to f6 we can move to d6
it really doesn't matter let's move it
to f6 and keep it on the long diagonal
and we still have the idea of going a4
a3 that's the point i've been trying to
make
at several points today is even though
queens can be traded that doesn't mean
you should forget about attacking um
okay well let's think about this for a
second if we go
a4 his knight can position itself on d4
that's sort of annoying can we prevent
preemptively his knight from coming to
d4 without
without ruining the bishop's control
over the long diagonal
yeah c5 how about this move and then
once we play
for the knight is to drop back in turn
that will allow us to go a3 and shatter
his entire queen side
so these prophylactic moves are really
the oil that makes the machine run
we didn't have to play it we're up a
piece but i'm trying to illustrate the
general concept right of
preemptively stopping retreating squares
when you can afford it sometimes you
can't afford to do that
okay
if he pushes b3 then he gives up the c3
pawn
and more importantly his entire position
is ruined so now we're going to oh
now we're going to take we're going to
start looking for tactics okay so
let's gather the data here our bishop is
hanging
our bishop is hanging um so and our
bishop actually doesn't have that many
good squares but that's okay
why is that okay because we have a lot
of tactical concepts in this position
that we can
that we can rely on now rook before
check a lot of people are seeing
but then he's got knight b3 and
amazingly
he sort of survives there or so it seems
but actually if we calculate a little
bit further and we give this check
his knight is now pinned the rook is not
hanging because of the pin and there's
no way for him to get to my bishop
so we can just play c4 this is
essentially a trade
but it's a good trade because we
preserve the attacking chances he takes
our bishop we take his knight
and then the c file gets open and we can
use that c file to get to the c3 pawn if
that makes sense
i probably didn't find the best way to
play it doesn't matter
we're completely winning we can go rook
c8 forcing his rook to a passive square
and then we're going to be up a piece
we've simplified the position
and the rest is a matter of just picking
up the hanging pawns so to speak
okay yeah this isn't the best but i
illustrated a nice concept i think and
we're still completely winning so
okay rookie three is good now what we're
gonna do we're gonna go g5
we're going to isolate this weak pawn on
f5
we're gonna just look around the board
and turn the vacuum cleaner on i call
this turning the vacuum cleaner on
we're just picking up his weak pawns
what are his weak pawns that we can get
to
what are the pawns that we can like get
to here there are two that i'm thinking
of
the first is the f5 pawn which we just
created the second is the h fun
and we can swing the rook around and win
the h-bun remember that the ultimate
idea in such end games
is to create a past fun so from that
perspective taking this pawn is good
because then we can start pushing the
h-bot and i'm actually ignoring this
deliberately and i'm even ignoring a
check on h2 because this pawn is going
to go so fast
and you guys will see that he simply has
doesn't have the firepower to stop it
watch watch how quickly this pawn just
runs to infinity
right exactly so now we're just going to
get our rook back and then run this punt
up the board i don't care about anything
else
all i'm going to look for is whether he
threatens my rook you got to be careful
you don't want to be too cavalier about
these positions here
he's not going to be able to stop it
whoa look who's here
gm hikaru thank you five gifted from
the man himself ikaru thank you i
really appreciate it uh wow
i think he's got a thing or two to learn
from the speedrun you know
after all i don't think he's fully
grasped some of these concepts uh
you know and uh thank you thank you car
really appreciate that
thank you youtube congratulations that
was well done and uh i really appreciate
that
okay uh so what is our goal in this
position our goal is to
get his king onto a square where we can
where we can check it with the rook if
we
if we were to move our rook right now
anywhere he would simply take on h2
so we need to use tactics to draw his
king
to a checkable square and that square
would be c3
so we notice the square on c3 we capture
twice
and now we've gotten the king onto a
checkable square
such that we can now promote to a queen
check yeah we can fossilize him here
check
i'll take the juicer and now the mate is
very simple we just ladder check made
him on h3
right good game and um
yeah i'm gonna slow this down for the
sake of you know certain gm's who might
not
understand the pace okay um
basically this was a modern which we
play
and um we took on e4 which
is the common tactic in these positions
i've talked about this before
when you see this and you see a knight
on f6 you should connect the dots
and play knight takes e4 to break into
his center
um and the best way of dealing with this
in my opinion
how can white deal with this to preserve
his bishop and not give up a pawn
like what is the sort of move that is
often played in these positions
well the perk starts with d6 it's
actually very often transposes into each
other
bishop d3 and now you take on e4
and now we can go after this pawn we can
go knight d7 and c5
and attack the pawn thank you justin
hykus and black basically liquidates
white's center black is doing
very much fine here that is why knight
e4 is good but he decided to take on f7
okay and um
that's the reason we played h6 is to
prevent his knight from accessing the g5
square that would not have been that
dangerous
so this is an example of where i as a gm
might have played differently right i
might have just developed my knight
or developed my bishop but i want to
illustrate this concept of playing
prophylactically to you guys
right so d5 knight g5 and what can
happen here
is that he gets his knight to e6 and he
forces us to give up our light squad
bishop
and this leads to a host of unpleasant
consequences uh does that make sense
so that's why we start with h6 we
deprive the knight of the square
and only after he goes c3 do we go d5
and the knight has to go to an inferior
square then g5
so knight c6 now we develop and he
blunders his bishop here after this
everything was very obvious
he probably should have done this first
this would have made bishop f4 possible
and can somebody remind me
what did we plan to do against
this move or against many other moves
thank you spencer lux for
let's hear one
so not g5 because that would create too
many weaknesses on the king side
right mr llama it does you're right but
the reality is
here well it also it all hinges on
us finding the next move knight g5 comes
with tempo it attacks the rook it makes
us lose time
that time allows him to increase his
control over e6 so the move
ladies and gentlemen is queen to d6 we
are doing two things
first of all we are we are bringing the
e5 square under control
and second of all we are stopping bishop
f4 why are we stopping bishop before
because we can take
earning us two pieces for a rook which
is very good for black
okay the logic should be pretty simple
here um
queen to d6 and also we're potentially
preparing e5 which would liquidate us
from the weakness
so at this level it all kind of depends
on tempe and concreteness
right the concept can be correct but the
execution can be wrong thank you spiro
man
for the tier one but he blunders the
bishop and now everything is very simple
we bring our pieces in
and now knight takes c5 was like the key
move thank you dragon x if queen takes
f4 then knight d3 check with a
discovered track and winning the queen
well jockeys if you consider the
material
sort of if you literally consider the
math uh usually bishops and knights are
considered three points each and a rook
is considered five points with six
against five
but that doesn't tell the whole story in
the middle game two pieces for a rook is
usually good for the two pieces
in the end game there could be a
confounding factor
a rook and this is something people
should remember when you have
no other pieces on the board a rook is
often very much superior
to two pieces uh because rooks are more
mobile
and they could go around vacuuming up
pawns it can be much harder for the
bishop and the knight for example
to coordinate in time to prevent the
rook from
you know running amok and taking pawns
and supporting passers
so if you have an endgame you need to be
careful if you have a middle game two
pieces usually better than a rook
okay so the really only interesting
moment of this game
which i didn't fully explain i think is
here
so c5 right we want to play a4 and the
logic that you should be using right
when you're considering a move
can i play move x and you say well where
can my opponent move his piece knight d4
yeah we can trade but i'm trying to
illustrate the concept here can we
take that square away from him first yes
we can
c5 and then we want to play a4 how can i
determine whether a trade is good for me
or not well
i mean look i can't give you an
algorithm what i'm trying to do here is
show you how i do these kinds of things
in the game
but um basically at the bottom line
you you want to weigh whether your piece
is better than your opponent's piece and
i think this bishop is on the long
diagonal
it can support an attack and i don't
really want to give it up unless i have
to
i ended up giving up the other bishop
and it is precisely
the dark square bishop which ultimately
won me the game this bishop was
responsible
yeah i think i'm going too fast for
hikaru he i don't think he's
he's following this uh rook takes c3
the reason this works is because the
bishop controls the c3 square
does that make sense